what up space fan goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again with
another one peace video the response on
the yong-chol vid was awesome so I
figured I'd go on and do a video about
all of the shisha bukai aka warlords of
the sea and their powers explained
although they're currently disbanded
we're going over all the former members
if you enjoy seeing one piece videos on
this channel and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button share this video
with a friend if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or else you
will miss future one piece videos as
usual manga spoilers are fair game in
these videos you've been warned now
without further ado let's jump into it
the idea behind those seven warlords of
the sea is that pirates would become
privateers working for the world
government that used to happen
historically with pirates where it was
not uncommon for them to switch back and
forth between pirate and privateer for a
specific nation in one piece they were
one of the three great powers along with
the yonk oh and the marine headquarters
that kept the world in balance it was a
pretty fun organization since the
Pirates were allied with the government
on paper but they didn't tend to care or
respect the government that much rather
than being loyal puppets of the
government most of these pirates join
because it served their own purposes at
the time the Warlord's also didn't get
along especially well with one another
either and most wouldn't make a habit of
helping each other now let's jump to one
of my favorite characters in the entire
series dracool Hawkeye's mihawk mihawk
holds the title of being the greatest
swordsman in the world he's 41 years old
before the time-skip in 43 years old
after the time skill when Zorro a legend
himself first fought me hawk me hawk
didn't even use his real sword saying
and I quote I'm not the kind of fool who
hunts rabbits with a cannon and quote he
used a smallest knife he had against
zoro's three swords and completely
outclassed him still though me hawk
respected Zoro's bravery and it had the
honor of defeating him with his actual
sword me hawk can easily destroy huge
ships with his sword or even giant
icebergs he's so strong that some people
think he has a devil fruit power but so
far it's been suggested that all of his
power comes from
natural abilities mihawk hasn't been
harmed during the series even though he
participated in the battle at Marine
Ford where many of the strongest
fighters in the series were present he
showed up because he wanted to and I
quote measured the true distance between
that man and us and quote he wanted to
see how strong white beard known as The
Strongest Man the world truly was in
person another extremely high fact about
me Hawk is that he used to be on coach
shanks his rival they used to have duels
but me Hawk stop fighting shanks after
the young cold losses are according to
me Hawk he doesn't challenge one-armed
husband's the debate rages on about
who's stronger but me Hawk strongly
implies here that he could beat the
yong-chol one-on-one now and no one
present tries to argue with him not
shanks or his crew members we know from
his conversation with Zorro that me
Hawks big talk can be backed up and he
even implied back then that he has the
ability to sense who would win in a
fight without fighting thus it's totally
possible to argue that me Hawk is
stronger than shanks one-on-one but
shanks is more dangerous because of his
skilled crew
there's also reason he's called dracool
Hawk eyes me hawk his vision is amazing
and he can easily track a faraway and
fast-moving Luffy in the middle of an
extremely busy battlefield at marine
four he shows how quick he is to here
since it takes him practically no time
to close the distance and get to Luffy
me Hawk trained Zorro for two years in
swordsmanship during the time skip but
Zorro admits that he's still nowhere
near me Hawks level
Miha can use observation haki and
armament haki
he teaches sorrel how to infuse his
swords with hockey so that they don't
break in fact me Hawk tells him that
every Nick on a sword is a mark of shame
it's also hype AF that me Hawk slash is
referred to the world's most powerful
sword slash usually you'd expect a sword
to be a worse weapon than a gun because
it can't reach far however B Hawk never
has trouble blocking bullets and his air
slashes can reach further in our way way
more destructive than bullets lastly as
you might expect me Hawk has great
mental strength to match his physical
strength not only did he never seem to
be affected by strong hockey and could
always withstand shanks is immense haki
as far as we can tell he also never
seemed affected by beau Hancock
charms even though most men are I can
always talk about me hot some more but
since this isn't just a me Hawk video
let's now move on to the next warlord
pirate Empress beau Hancock beau is the
captain of the Kuja pirate and arguably
best girl in one piece she's the current
Empress of Amazon Lily boy is playing 9
years old before the time skip and 31
years old after but that doesn't stop
her from falling in love with our
considerably younger protagonist Luffy
she possesses the meadow meadow no me
aka the love love fruit boa can turn
people who love her or lust after her
into stone it's not that difficult
either because her level of beauty is
legendary she can also turn her victims
back to normal - if a person is feeling
no lust or cannot see her then Boas
powers won't work on them it is also
possible for people to force their lust
out of their mind using pain for
instance vice-admiral Momonga stabbed
his hand and this kept him from being
affected Luffy is immune to her powers
because of his pure heart something he
has in common with Goku from Dragon Ball
it seems that people with strong
willpower can resist her to like me Hawk
crocodile and smoker interestingly
enough boa can turn things she touches
into stone so the power is not just lust
based
she uses this ability in conjunction
with her impressive hand-to-hand combat
skills in order to instantly turn parts
of people's bodies into stone and then
break them off with her powerful kicks
she even uses this ability to beat
multiple non-human pacifist us who are
notoriously tough like Luffy boa can
even use all three types of haki
including observation haki armament haki
and the rare conquers haki it's
noteworthy that boy uses her big snake
Salome in battle it has served as Boas
personal throne elevator and tracker
Salome cares deeply about boa and
assists her in any way it can what a
good pet snake next let's look at the 39
year old buggy the star clown this
legend almost needs no introduction but
let me mention that he was an apprentice
along with Yakko shanks on pirate king
Goldie Rogers crew he's also the captain
of the buggy pirates he possesses the
bada Bonanomi aka the chop-chop fruit
buggies fruit makes him immune to
cutting or piercing attacks
you got to hit him with blunt blows like
when luffy kicked him in the groin his
body can split up into many different
parts all of which he can control as
long as they stay in his effective area
the parts can levitate except for his
feet as Luffy Illustrated a drawback of
the power is that all of the separate
parts will feel pain so if you capture
one part you can do a lot of damage to
buggy another crazy fact is that buggies
levitating body parts can even lift much
larger people like Jinbei and fly around
with them although blades have no effect
on him buggy likes using them against
his opponents he's even had some hidden
in his shoes before like a true pirate
buggy uses cannonballs called buggy
balls in battle along with hand grenades
called muggy balls it's worth noting
that buggy is the natural enemy of sword
users since even the strongest swordsman
like Zorro and me Hawk can't cut him
next up let's look at the 35 year old
Edward weevil aka white beard jr. he is
the self-proclaimed son of white beard
and his mustache is definitely familiar
this dude is a monster in his own right
he took out 16 former white beard
captains and their crews it's common for
we will to blow a town off the map over
an argument in one case there were 600
estimated casualties Borsellino and Opie
dude himself praises weevil calling him
tremendously powerful he compares him to
the real white beard in his youth in
terms of strength which is a huge
compliment white beard was known as the
strongest man in the world after all we
will even wield Onaga Nauta which was
white beard weapon of choice - in a
one-piece data book it was revealed that
weevil can use armament haki and
observation haki weevil has no known
devil fruit to speak of but he had the
highest known former bounty of all the
Warlord's
480 million berries which is insane to
think about of course now former warlord
and current Yong Co black beard has a
bigger bounty of well over two billion
berries weevil hasn't had a huge role
yet in the story but he's definitely one
of the wildcards that I'm excited to see
more of in the future he has reasons to
hate black beard after what he did to
white beard so he may somehow even end
up helping Luffy down the line against
the genius yank oh speaking of the
genius Yong Co let's talk about the 40
year-old black beard next
this dude is easily
one of the most interesting characters
in the series and that's not a
coincidence
the historical Blackbeard was probably
the most famous pirate ever and you can
bet that Oda would give that notorious
name to a deserving character Marshall
DT is an antagonist you can't help but
respect the dude has exercised insane
patience and cunning in order to carry
out his master plans
he waited decades for the dark dark
fruit and managed to convince everyone
that he wasn't ambitious during all that
time even though he's arguably the most
ambitious dude in the series he became a
warlord just so he could break powerful
individuals out of prison and get them
to join his crew his actions led to the
Battle of marine fort & Blackbeard used
the battle to steal white beards opie
devil fruit after the two warring sides
had all but destroyed each other what a
scary dude he is he went on to defeat
Marco the Phoenix and the rest of white
beards men that were present at the
grudge war it was after this major
battle that Blackbeard was first
included among the list of the four
Emperor's he is now the only man to
possess two devil fruits at once and
they happened to be two of the most
powerful devil fruits in one piece
according to Blackbeard the Yami Yami no
me ake a dark dark fruit is said to be
the most dangerous power in the history
of all devil fruits
it's a loggia it lets Blackbeard create
and manipulate darkness he can suck
things into his darkness and compress
the objects with immense power and crush
them he did this with a town and then
released all of the wreckage he explains
the age that his darkness sucks and
everything so he can't avoid physical
attacks like other logia users however
his fruit can pull in the bodies of
devil fruit users and to use
Blackbeard's own words he can absorb the
power of the devil fruits when he was
touching ace ace couldn't use his devil
fruit powers and Blackbeard could
deliver a powerful blow as we know he
stole the gudaguda know me a key the
tremor tremor fruit from white beard
Blackbeard called it the power of the
earthquake that destroys everything
after he got it he proclaimed himself to
be invincible and the greatest the
tremor tremor fruit is concerned to be
the strongest paramecia fruit it allows
the user to create vibrations and
shockwaves that can travel through
almost anything including air ground and
water it has been used to create massive
earthquakes and tsunamis Whitebeard used
the power to take down
part of the Navy headquarters and to
create a huge chasm in order to split up
the warring sides during the battle at
marine fort now this crazy power is in
Blackbeard's hands according to a
1-piece data book Blackbeard can use
both observation haki and armament haki
besides that he seems to possess a
superhuman body Marko calls his body odd
and says that maybe that explains why
he's able to possess two devil fruits at
once it's also been said that he doesn't
sleep and he's taking close attacks
including from white beard that would
have killed or seriously injured other
men and he's always bounced back
relatively quickly he's definitely a
force to be reckoned with he's arguably
the most dangerous young co and when he
proclaimed that his era was beginning
those clearly weren't empty words next
let's look at the twenty six-year-old
trafalgar D water law aka the surgeon of
that he's the captain and doctor of the
heart pirates and an all-around cool
dude he became a warlord during the time
skip but it was revoked when he teamed
up with Luffy and helped him take down
though Flamengo he possesses the Opa Opa
no me a KD op op fruit he can create a
sphere around him and a smoker points
out everyone inside the sphere is a
helpless patient on lost operating table
he reigns supreme within that space and
is able to spatially manipulate what's
in it in the space he can effortlessly
split ships in half split people in half
stop bullets take people's hearts and so
on
he has telekinetic like powers that let
him move objects or teleport them by
switching locations of different objects
with each other
you can also create electrical surges
and these shocks can be strong enough to
take down opponents the op op Routh user
can perform a personality switching
surgery which allows him to swap
people's souls and in the hands of a
skilled enough user the fruit can
apparently give eternal life through the
immortality operation the user would
lose their life though after giving
someone else eternal life because of
this latter ability it's been called the
ultimate devil fruit after the time-skip
laws ability covers a much larger area
suggesting that the area of his matrix
room could continue to grow as he
matures the fruit is perfect for a
doctor since it can be used to cure
illnesses it can practically extract
anything from the human body and law
used to cure himself of the amber lead
poisoning inside his BA
which was originally supposed to kill
him by the age of 13 in addition to his
devil fruit law as a skilled swordsman
and he often uses his sword in
conjunction with his devil fruit powers
he also possesses armament haki and
observation haki next let's look at the
46 year old Jim Bey who longs for
equality between humans and Fishman
it's amazing that luffy was lucky enough
to get this Opie fish man to join his
crew Jinbei used to be the second
captain of the Sun Pirates he fought on
equal terms with ace who had the help of
an awesome low gear power and even a
yong-chol like big mom knew she was
losing a lot of power when he said he
was leaving the big bomb pirates Jim Bay
has great willpower and bravery big mom
couldn't use her powers to take his
lifespan because he didn't feel the
tiniest bit of fear his response was
also epic he said and I quote a man who
would be crewmate of the future king of
pirates cannot afford to tremble in the
presence of a mere Emperor you can't
help a respect someone who talks like
that in front of big mom Jim Bay was
placed in level six of impel down the
lowest level where the most dangerous
inmates are placed when he refused to
fight white beard inmates on this level
are usually all given the death sentence
or a life sentence in her often erased
from history
however jinbei was given a temporary
sentence clearly though his power is
well respected if they felt like they
had to put him on level six
Jim Bay survived attacks from some of
the strongest characters in the series
like a canoe and big mom as a fish man
his capabilities are increased further
in the water he is a master of fish man
karate and even became a black Bell as a
child
Jimbo even knows how to use the secret
Fishman karate art food icon or vagabond
drill that sent the young ko big mom
flying back off of their ship as if he
wasn't great enough already he can also
communicate with animals of the sea for
instance he can give precise orders that
whale sharks will follow he is a skilled
user of armament haki and observation
haki all in all having djembe join
Luffy's crew was an extremely exciting
development for me and I hope to see
much more of him in the future
next let's look at the cool and
intelligent 46 year old desert king sir
crocodile he was the president of
baroque works in the main antagonist of
the
alabasta Ark he was also jim bayes
impelled down level six neighbor which
shows how dangerous and powerful he is
he lost the warlord title after he
attempted to take over alabasta with
Luffy's help he escaped from impelled
out and participated in the battle of
marine fort after which him and his man
das bones pieced out to the new world
although Luffy beat crocodile eventually
he had significant help from nico robin
who saved him multiple times if not for
her luffy would not have succeeded it's
also unfortunate for crocodile that
something as common as blood nullified
his logia fruit defenses so yeah luffy
beat him relatively early on but that
doesn't mean we should underestimate his
power during the bala marine ford he had
encounters with doflamingo me hawk and
even a chi nu and survived just fine
he even talked down to me hawk the
strongest swordsman in the world after
stopping his slash with his hook
crocodile said he was in a bad mood and
then warned the strongest swordsman to
watch himself what a fricking boss let's
take a closer look at his devil fruit
power the suna suna Nomi a Kaede the
sand sand fruit as the name suggests the
fruit allows crocodile to turn into sand
and control any sand around him he can
reflexively turn into sand and so he was
fine when doflamingo suddenly tried to
take off his head during the battle at
marine port in the past he has created
quicksand and sandstorms crocodile can
also absorb the moisture of anything he
grabs he can dehydrate people in plants
and turn rocks and solid earth into sand
although the ability won't work on
metallic things crocodile can create
sharp blades out of sand and use them to
fight when wet crocodile sand hardens
and can't disperse at will so that is
his weakness however if he makes her to
absorb the liquid in his opponent first
then there's no problem
crocodile can use his logia fruit to fly
by turning his lower body into sand and
he's obviously more powerful in a desert
area where he has a lot of sand to work
with all in all crocodiles are forced to
be reckoned with because of his mastery
over his devil fruit and because of his
intelligence I'm really glad that they
brought him back after alabasta because
he's proven to be a very cool character
and maybe he'll help Luffy and his crew
again in the future next up we have the
fashionably dressed
41 year old donquixote doflamingo
the former captain of the Don Quixote
pirates and former king of dressrosa in
addition to being a former warlord he
was also a former world noble and a
former underworld Broker under the very
cool codename
Joker doflamingo is so strong that law a
warlord himself was an Opie devil fruit
power knows that he needs to conserve
all of the strength he can for
doflamingo doflamingo also has no
problem overpowering a skilled logia
user like Vice Admiral smoker he even
appeared to effortlessly overpower
fellow warlord gecko Moria after the
battle at marine Ford calling him too
weak to be a warlord although he did
also have a bunch of pacifist as present
helping him nonetheless it speaks to a
strength that he was the one entrusted
to take out warrior though flamingo's
influence was great if he as a warlord
declared someone to be a subordinate
their past crimes would be overlooked
and they could no longer be arrested by
the government as was the case with
Caesar clown he could pull the strings
needed pun intended to falsify the
newspapers because he knows about Mary
Jo eases national treasure he could
blackmail the celestial dragons in the
past in order to exercise some of those
insane celestial dragon privileges like
commanding cp0
now let's look at his eat Alito Nomi a
cage string string fruit the devil fruit
power lets him create and control
strength he can use these strings to
control people as if they were puppets
or to slice things up the strings can be
so thin that they're invisible to the
human eye making them even more
difficult to avoid interestingly enough
he can attach his strings to clouds and
use them to seemingly fly over the sea
kind of like spider-man uses buildings
and his spidey strings to fly around New
York
doflamingo can perform a kind of
emergency surgery on himself where he
uses his strings to rapidly reconstruct
his organs this is how he continued to
fight even after law gave him a blow
that should have taken him out
doflamingo is so skilled that he has
awakened his devil fruit which lets him
turn surrounding objects like buildings
into string he also has an ultimate
technique that creates a large birdcage
of strings around the vast area he can
make the cage close in and cut
everything in its way it will disappear
if doflamingo loses consciousness but if
you're bugging a clown with your
spliting powers you could probably just
run through the strings and piece
in regards to hockey doflamingo is one
of the few individuals who possesses all
three kinds including observation haki
armament haki and conquerors haki
he can even infuse his strings with haki
to get logia users and that's it for the
snazzy dresser let's move on to the guy
he tried to eliminate the 50 year old
Gekko Moria captain of the thriller bark
pirates Moria used to be the captain of
the Gekko pirates but most of them were
eliminated when they clashed with Cairo
as a result Moria wants revenge and it's
pretty cool that someone after fighting
Kaido is still brave enough to want to
beat him in fact some people in the
world of one piece believe that Moria
was at least at one point tough enough
to go toe-to-toe against Cato obviously
we can't verify exactly how accurate
that statement is but the point is we
shouldn't be sleeping on maurya's
power.yes doflamingo cornered him with
some pacifist 'as after the Ballad
marine fort but even then he managed to
escape and now though flamingo is on the
sixth level of impel down while Moria is
still free as far as we know Blackbeard
even invited Moria to join his crew and
Blackbeard usually only wants the best
so that's another testament to moriya's
power Moria may well team up with
Blackbeard
if it means getting revenge on Kaido now
let's get into moriya's devil fruit the
kaga cogito me aka the shadow shadow
fruit the shadow fruit allows Moria
distinct people shadows into different
bodies he can stick them into dead
bodies in order to create zombies his
own shadows called Doppel man they can
use it to fight for him the Doppel man
can take any shape it can even break up
into many different shadow bats Adelman
is amazing in that it cannot be
destroyed and will simply reform again
and again Moria can trade places with
his shadow when he's in trouble or when
it's simply convenient when Moria steals
someone's shadow their real body will
disintegrate if they come into contact
with direct sunlight so you can really
inconvenience someone or even kill them
by stealing their shadow but if they die
their shadow will vanish too Moria can
also take the shadows into himself to
increase his size and strength he's
taken 1000 shadows into himself before
although he couldn't maintain that
extremely powerful form for long Moria
uses giant scissors as weapons they can
split apart and be used as swords or
they can be used to cut off people
shadows too
in battle I expect to see this vampire
zombie looking dude again and he really
may even pop up in mono to help defeat
Kaito next up we have the 47 year old
Bartholomew kuma this guy was everything
a king of the sorbet kingdom a
revolutionary a warlord a cyborg and so
on since his final pacifist ah
modifications it seems that he is a
complete slave of the world government
he possesses the Knik unique you know me
aka the Poppa fruit as a result he can
push or deflect anything he can push
things people or even pain he can fire a
pad cannon which is stronger than actual
cannon he deflects air pressure at
Lightspeed the attack leaves paw prints
and stoned it can even bring down
Frankie's metallic body he can also
create a giant bomb by compressing the
air around him this power is crazy in
the sense that he can push people and
send them flying to a desired
destination that could require days to
reach then as if that wasn't enough
there are his pacifist on modifications
to talk about the modifications enhance
his power but also rob him of his free
will as a cyborg he no longer feels pain
he can shoot laser beams from his mouth
which can melt steel and cause
explosions he also carries around a
Bible the other pacifist those made in
His image do not possess his devil fruit
powers and do not hold a Bible and that
is it for the Warlord's the title of
warlord is a thing of the past in one
piece but a lot of cool powerful
characters possess the title in the past
and I thought it would be cool to go
over them and they're interesting powers
if you enjoyed the video and want to see
more like it make sure to smash that
like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification belt or you will
miss future one piece videos let me know
in the comments if you want to see the
straw hats next the admirals or whatever
other category you're itching to see a
special thank you goes to our patrons
over on patreon who help us survive
YouTube issues and who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost I want to thank our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Steven and Greta a Lola attend the
world stealers the school bus Theisen
Kirino acquired respect and pattaya and
I can't forget our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Odin Anatole kazansky
alpha do angel Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan
Kapoor cricket XP $30 beat Ted no Ted
Salter
Joel Stanton very Gucci Jessica Kayla
fond and Perot Taku and JCC Wacha thank
you all so much if you enjoy our work
you can support more rate by going over
to patreon common lore and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course dank memes so
check out patreon.com/lenguin
if you prefer whichever way you choose
to support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]